non c'est beaucoup mieux de regarder
quelques extraits ceux de ce
documentaire en quinze jours j'étais
capable de faire 90 euros c est tout
j'avais obtenu aucun tabou je faisais de
tout mais vraiment tout je vous dis en
vérité c'était pour clash je prenne
encore par jour quand je prenais aussi
un peu de coke à côté mais vraiment je
me faisais vas-y je me suis toujours
juré déjà me tchessa mais je prenais
quoi on va dire de rails
j'ai acheté une voiture choisir j'avais
14 15 ans en fait c'est une voiture
d'occasion
je me rappelle c'est une audi a3 alors
avant d'en parler ça nécessite d'avoir
plusieurs parce que c'est un sujet qui a
beaucoup fait parler qui a été suivi par
plus de 2 millions de téléspectateurs
donc c'est pas du tout négligeable dans
les politiques parlent depuis parce que
à la machine à café on commande beaucoup
et on va regarder une autre vidéo sur le
main sur l'argent facile évidemment j'ai
vu quelqu'un petit à petit change et une
petite fille ma petite fille mourir un
peu vain puisque j'ai fait le deuil de
ma petite fille faut le dire j'ai pris
son téléphone portable j'ai demandé
facture détaillée j'ai appelé tous les
clients voilà je me suis dit moi quand
une dizaine mais bon c'est pas grave
j'ai pu constater aussi qu'il y avait un
désarroi la part des clients qui
disaient que je ne savais pas que
c'était des mineurs mon bon c'est vrai
que qui m'a jamais laissé sans nouvelles
et elle m'a toujours tout dit même si
des fois où j'aurais aimé ajustements
qui est un sas pour qu'elle puisse
parler parce que moi j'entendais des
choses qui étaient violentes pour moi en
tant que maman et je prenais de plein
fouet ce qu'elle avait subi dans son
corps et dans son âme aussi lancé la
mère d'une enfant qui parle au palais
bourbon de vendôme va devant les
politiques adorent franchise car vous
aurez signé du chef pour moi parce que
je trouve que c'est un reportage
terrible mais à la fois nécessaire mais
vraiment vraiment nécessaire moi je là
je vais vous parler en tant que maman
quand j'ai écouté le témoignage de ces
mamans g est évidemment terrifié mais je
me suis dit à quel point c'est important
parce qu'il ya plein de mamans qui ne
savent pas que ça existe que c'est
possible dans tous les milieux bien
évidemment qu'on ne s'en rend pas
forcément compte
et pourquoi il était nécessaire parce
qu'effectivement vous l'avez dit non
seulement ça fait ça fait bouger aussi
le gouvernement on l'avait vu il y avait
un reportage sur m6 sur l'aide sociale à
l'enfance et ensuite s'il s'était passé
plein de trucs donc s'il faut passer
par là et ben moi je trouve ça super
important alors c'était dur à regarder
mais mais c'était vraiment nécessaire
quoi franchement bravo ami a priori car
beaucoup beaucoup frappé des gens c'est
la façon dont elle en parle le cache
effectivement et notamment cette
adolescente qui parle de l'argent
qu'elles gagnent alors qu'elle a moins
de 15 ans 1 à part dont autant contents
pour moi je crois qu'on est fabuleux
celui de la jeune fille qui gagnent
jusqu'à 90 milles euros donc vous
beaucoup critiquer tout de même en
disant que c'était c'était ça allait
trop loin que c'était tronque était ce
nécessaire d'en faire autant donc gilles
vous avez quelque chose à dire là dessus
a beaucoup été critiqué sur le thème que
la journaliste clarisse verrier
accompagne un peu trop les jeunes femmes
c'est à dire que à force d'être avec
elle pendant presque deux ans elle les
laisse parler mais moi je suis pas du
tout d'accord avec ça que ce sont des
jeunes femmes qui ont besoin de
s'exprimer
ah oui et comme pour expurger ce
qu'elles ont en elles donc il fallait
qu'elle parle il fallait que ça serve
d'exemple
et si vous ne leur inspire et pas
confiance à ses jeunes femmes elles ne
parleront jamais donc leurs proches de
la connivence qui a été fait aux
journalistes je le trouve ignoble parce
que c'est vraiment pour un documentaire
un travail que je trouve exemplaire
voilà absolument aucun deux jours aucun
de vous ne parlez pour l'instant
d'internet or une mère l'une des mères
convoi dans le dans documents de zone
interdite explique qu'elle a tout
découvert un rang qu'elle a vu sa fille
sur internet
aujourd'hui hélas 14 et elle se
prostitue depuis quel âge d'après vous
depuis ses deux ans j'ai trouvé la photo
de ma fille est dans un site de
prostitution c'est voilà une autre photo
cb oui oui oui je connais
la forme soit votre essai de 12 ans et
pas de 14 ans parce qu'elle a pris du
poids et elle a grandi ça veut dire que
depuis longtemps oui ça veut dire que ça
c'est fait je connais très bien la
patrie de ma fille je m'aime c'est moi
qui ai acheté ses soutiens gorge qu'on
est le grain de beauté
là je sais c'est ma fille alors il ya
aussi une mère qui se fait passer pour
un client pour envoyer un message ce
sera la dernière vidéo qu'on regardera
parce qu'il y en a aussi des plus
violentes donc nous on ne concède pas la
tentation de trop montré non plus et
elle découvre que c'est peut-être pas sa
fille qui écrit ce qu'elle est supposée
écrire vous avez envoyé un message comme
si vous étiez un client oui c'est ça
mais la réponse à ma fille je la connais
elle écrit pas très bien le français
sauf que là je suis passé par une langue
qui s'appelle sami et la réponse était
bonjour sami je vois que mon profil ne
te laisse pas indifférent c'est dommage
que je ne puisse pas vous voir en retour
sinon que l'on recherche sur le site
bison voilà je vois nathalie il n'y a
pas quelqu'un qui écrit comme ça a
laissé jean michel parent dont je vous
ai pas entendu le savez c'est l'arrêt ce
que nous restions ya pas nadeau qui
écrit comme ça c'est vrai les ados y
décrivait idée raccourcir souhaite tuer
le tirer entre le souhaitent et tuent et
cetera c'est vrai que c'est carrément
quelqu'un un proxénète certainement qui
vous quelqu'un qui en tout cas qui fait
usage de office de prochaine qui écrit à
sa place c'est ça qui est terrible
je crois pas que des policiers parce que
visiblement c'est pas très dur d'aller
sur ces sites
bompas clé la police tôt pas plus
efficace dans la recherche et qui peut
justement il ya on s'essuie on suit même
un procès où il ya donc des jeunes
proxénètes qui sont inquiétés et en fait
on voit qu'ils sont très vite libéré que
les peines ne sont pas du tout à la
hauteur je pense que souvent ça les
minutes filent femme est chargée des
mineurs ont aussi en fait c'est le
système qui a changé cercle maintenant
on a des jeunes qui qui prostituées des
jeunes qui se prostituent et donc on n'a
plus les clés les clés judiciaire pour
venir à bout de ces condamnations
francesca oui la main oui mais attendez
à l'entente alors je sors c'est juste
une information n'est pas une opinion
dans le documentaire et disent
abandonnés qui gagnent ils risquent
moins en faisant du trafic d'êtres
humains la drogue que en faisant du
trafic de drogue et que le bénéfice est
plus immédiat
c'est une donnée que moi j
resca raison parce que même la preuve on
voit dans le reportage abandonné la
gamine elle vient avec son mec qui était
là dans l'appartement
hambourg qu'elle se prostitue donc c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué la dénonciation
elle est vraiment elle est limitée elle
est souvent prise donc c'est à dire que
la la la gamine elle peut pas
sincèrement donner tous tous et toutes
les informations qu'a là parce que ben
est là encore sous l'emprise du truc
elles sont hyper jeunes faut pas
l'oublier et on peut pas remettre tout
ça sur le dos des parents parce qu'ils
sont même dépourvus de tout moyen parce
que c'est l'inimaginable effectivement
qui s'affairent mer le disent abandonnés
et alors vous est ce que si vous n'aviez
pas eu à le regarder pour des raisons
professionnelles
est-ce que vous l'auriez est ce que vous
auriez eu envie de le regarder ça change
c'est anxiogène et que ça aurait pu être
davantage regarder encore non mais
franchement moi je ne savais pas que
j'allais bosser aujourd'hui j'ai pas pu
quitter l'émission 30 secondes
franchement c'était prenant ces des
reportages chocs mais nécessaire voilà
c'est d'utilité publique les gens qui
regardent ça voilà ils doivent savoir
que ça existe et il a devancé les salles
à quel point ça peut arriver jeunes donc
voila moi c'est un sujet franchement que
je trouve oui c'est ça peut être clivant
ça peut être difficile à entendre mais
c'est hyper important pour tous les
parents à savoir que ça existe alors
lille et truc c'est que beaucoup de
personnes vont parler de voyeurisme mais
là moi je ne vois pas de voyeurisme
étant donné qu'à un moment donné on
n'était pas au courant ou que s'il y
avait autant d'ampleur sur ce sujet là
quand on regarde les choses sur la
drogue bon bah on le sait ça peut être
du voyeurisme et les chaussures les
cambriolages tout ce qu'on veut mais ça
moi je pense quand même être un peu dans
le mouv la vague je sais pas comment on
dit et je pense être au courant de ce
qui se passe un peu et ça je ne pensais
pas qu'il y en avait autant en france à
ce point là des jeunes mineurs qui se
prostituait donc je pense que c'est elle
c'est est d'une utilité pour réveiller
les gens et leur dire attention et
surtout bouger ses bonhommes qui vont
appeler ces gamines la cantèra russe
devant lui et calot qu'ils repartent
tout de suite au lieu de rester comme
elle l'expliquait dans le reportage
et vous qui lie qui nous avait parlé ya
pas longtemps des kardashian et sur
l'argent facile il ya justement une mise
en cause mais la télé réalité ça nous
faire plaisir j'ai un line et notamment
dès que des kardashian est une gamine
qui dit elle a trop trop de foule alors
elle dit est la trotteuse tout est juste
avant elle dit bon c'est vrai à la payer
ses fesses dit d'une autre manière
mais bon à la tro tro dessous donc c'est
vrai qu'on en revient au même si
j'ai qui est la dangerosité des réseaux
sociaux et des genre de nanas comme
kardashian qui sont adulés par des
jeunes de 15 ans yes man adulé par des
adultes bien là enfin c'est leur
problème
on s'en fiche chacun fait ce qu'il veut
mais quand c'est adulé par des jeunes
filles de 15 ans d'où en or on en
revient sur le même truc que seul un
grammage pour l instant g de toute façon
ne devraient pas être autorisés pour les
jeunes de cet âge là c'est pas une
prostituée kim kardashian quand même
parce que hassiba mais elle a sillonné
jeudi soir c'est quand même basé sur une
tactique mais sinon ça si tu es
sacrément c'est de cela les mots ont un
sens on peut pas dire qu'en kardashian
prostituées c'est absolument pas passer
l'été avec son candidat commun mais elle
admire sa sextape son corps c'est à la
voix douce à nos experts et elle a fait
son fond de commerce sur une vidéo de
cuche avait pas de la prostitution mais
rien pour revenir sur le reportage
il y aurait en france de sybille à dix
mille mineurs qui se prostituent mais le
mais le gym il
mais le chiffre est sans doute
sous-estimé et à moi je connais par
exemple le cas dans le val de marne
qu'on voyait beaucoup dans le reportage
à créteil d'ailleurs les autorités
judiciaires ont participé aux reportages
parce qu à une mobilisation générale au
mieux au sommet de l'état sur ce sujet
là et on voit que c'est très difficile
parce que pour répondre à jean michel
les filières entre guillemets sont
extrêmement volatiles
c'est à dire que vous avez sur un une
ville un endroit qui est loué par des
moyens de location très rapide avec des
jeunes femmes qui sont prostituées
contraintes et puis ça bouge d'une ville
à l'autre avec des réseaux très mobiles
donc c'est infernal c'est pour ça qu'ils
ont attiré l'attention la en facilitant
en disant ça ne peut plus durer parce
que c'est un phénomène qui est dans une
expansion folle c'est incroyable
absolument et jean-michel que je trouve
étonnamment silencieux de nos revenus
parce que parce que j'écoute cette info
il faut savoir quand même que la
majorité m'attendais des prostituées non
plus de souteneur le fait que le nom
alors le souteneur allant scène ça
n'existe plus ça internet qu'a créé ma
tante est fier de son protégé le sont
plus
c'est même les a rachetés à acheter une
rude deux gamines pour ses dix mille
euros
la majorité la position aujourd'hui je
connais j'en connais quelques unes parce
que m'a-t-on dit plus prostituées
m'a-t-on dit escorte ce exact j'ai
justement regarde lessard de la
sémantique
amandine et sa copine tombe ensuite dans
un piège elles sont entraînées à paris
pour faire la fête les se retrouve
séquestré dans un appartement en réalité
elles ont été vendues à des proxénètes
c'est l'incompréhension donc là je lui
explique que je suis mineur que j'ai que
quinze ans que je sois encore vierge
pour le coup que jamais eu de rapports
et les et me regarder le gia avait en
fait c'est pas possible je peux pas
entendre sa voix vous deux vous et payer
7000 euros bougera pas d'ici
amandine tentent de fuir mais elle se
fait tabasser avant d'être relâchés
malgré ce calvaire elle se prostitue six
mois plus tard pourtant consciente
qu'elle se fait du mal pour les hommes
ça m'horrifie maintenant je regarde les
hommes j'ai envie de les tuer un par
jour soit une montre ou violet voilà qui
est difficile d'enchaîner après ça c'est
sans doute pour moi la séquence la pluie
les séquences les plus fortes et elle
retournera à la prostitution peu après
avoir voulu en sortir benjamin rien
d'autre a ajouté noam et c'est un
honneur réservé et c'est vrai que je
suis à l'exil moi je pensais pas que
c'était à ce point et dix mille dix
mille c'est un chiffre considérable et
ses jeux que je pense évidemment aux
enfants et je pense aux parents il faut
que les parents soient vigilants et voir
dans les téléphones de leurs enfants
pour à ce qui se passe que ça touche
tout part de là donc c'est très bien de
lancer ce genre d' alerte par la tenir
évidemment